pour qu'apparaisse la réouverture des
parcs souhaité par la mère anne hidalgo
a été refusée par le gouvernement les
habitants de la courneuve en
seine-saint-denis peuvent depuis hier
matin profiter du parc georges valbon
une réouverture expérimental après
l'obtention d'une dérogation du conseil
départemental et sous certaines
conditions très strictes
impossible par exemple de s'asseoir sur
les pelouse pour pique-niquer ou de
faire du sport en groupe
écoutez ces quelques réactions je suis
très contente parce que j'ai l'habitude
de venir faire mon footing au moins deux
fois par semaine et puis je marche
énormément avec mon mari donc j'habite
le bourget donc c'est vraiment pour nous
c'est vraiment la situation idéale pour
venir se promener prendre l'air le parc
est magnifique il est immense il ya des
lacs il ya des fontaines donc on peut
vraiment faire des bonnes promenade au
moins d'une heure voire deux heures sans
problème ça permet de s'oxygéner parce
que se promener dans paris c'est bien
mais sans pareil au même
on est obligé de saisir deux de se
rapprocher des gens qu'il n'ya pas
attraper la bon c'est aucun risque pour
moi il ya quinze ans les parcs non pour
voir ça risque rien parce que voyez il
ya de l'espace donc on risque pas de se
croiser à mettre quoi moi quand je veux
quelqu'un là je me décale voilà donc
pour moi ça reste que rien les parcs
enfin c'est parque là puisqu'il est
grand sud à damparis est différent le
parc monceau tout ça c'est trop là ça
serait trop confiné je pense